I don't know that there any writers that
really inform my work because I was
writing I didn't read a book till I was
24 and I've been writing for many many
years before that and my writing really
hasn't changed all that much I still
write about me which is what I did then
but there are certainly many writers I
admire when I started reading when I was
24 it was a revelation it was just the
most perfect experience and I once I
started I couldn't stop and I read as
much and as constantly as I could the
with the exception that i didn't read
dead authors so no classics and the
reason I wouldn't read a dead author is
because I would find an author whose
work I just loved and I read the next
book in the next book in the next book
and I always knew you know that next
year there'll be another book but with
the dead people with the dead ones once
you finish their last book there wasn't
going to ever be another book and the
author who broke that that pattern of
that spell was Edith Wharton when I read
the house of murph the House of Mirth
nearly killed me it was so brilliant and
that opened up a whole new world for me
you know it expanded my horizons and
it's been a constant process I mean I've
always reading and and and and new new
authors that I've never read before and
living and dead and all over the place
but there are tons of writers that I
love I love the writer you know you are
well teen I love Flannery O'Connor I
love Tilly Olson I love Carson McCullers
I love Elizabeth Berg I love Anita
Shreve I love Haven Kimmel I mean
there's so many writers that I just
really admire I read um the things I
don't read a lot of memoirs I don't read
memoirs I don't read essays what i read
i read fiction and i read
dad's books on cosmology astrophysics
and particle theory so the very tiny
tiny tiny and in the very very big those
are my interests
I read anyways the old man in the sea
and I was just like what you know what I
I just never got Hemingway you know I
mean I guess I get the whole Yang's
macho and the swaggering and the choppy
sentences but you know and in the end he
shoots himself in the head if we didn't
seem like a very happy guy um so I was
never I never I never I mean Hemingway
is now a line of furniture which is
great you know the Hemingway collection
is that Ethan Allen maybe and maybe that
was his destiny all along to become a
coffee table
with this surreal experience to see your
memoir turned into a film I mean it's
you know it's a it's a director and it's
the director's script and his vision of
your my memoir and it was exciting you
know I mean it was the cast was
absolutely astonishing and the
performances were amazing and it it was
surreal and it never did quite feel real
I didn't spend much time on the set I
was there for I think a day or Dana half
and I had to go to Australia um to tour
down there but I wouldn't have been on
the set anyway I mean I didn't want to
be you know the writer the guy who lived
sitting around eating eminem's and
judging everybody you know I didn't
laugh like that I didn't sneeze that way
I would have said I'm sorry but it was a
great experience I mean it was a
wonderful experience and I made you know
a couple of lasting friendships out of
it and is it was great
you